two days that could change the future of
Ukraine
not with weapons but with investment and
Aid and emphasizing the urgency the
Ukrainian president joined delegates in
London via video link
there is currently in your place in a
wall where there is a need to construct
and rebuild as many objects as in
Ukraine every new day of Russian address
brings new rules thousands thousands and
thousands of destroyed houses
devastated Industries around lives
kicking off the two-day Conference
standing next to the British and
Ukrainian foreign ministers Rishi sunak
stressed the importance of private
Enterprise investing in Ukraine and
that's why we're launching the Ukraine
business compact for the private sector
to pledge their support for Ukraine's
recovery and reconstruction
and I am delighted to announce today
that over 400 businesses from 38
countries with a combined market cap of
4.9 trillion dollars have now signed up
the U.S used the event to announce more
than a billion extra dollars of direct
Aid to Ukraine focused on energy and
infrastructure needs
the World Bank estimates the recovery
effort could cost around 440 billion
dollars no wonder they're talking about
a Marshall Plan for Ukraine making
comparisons with Europe's reconstruction
after World War II but a key difference
the conflict in Ukraine is far from over
idea being explored is how to use frozen
Russian assets to help Ukraine rebuild
even as we come together here in London
committed to supporting Ukraine's build
up Russia continues to try to burn it
down
so
let's be clear
Russia is causing Ukraine's destruction
and Russia will eventually bear the cost
of Ukraine's reconstruction
the figures being discussed here are
immense and they're meant to guarantee
Ukraine's Prosperity over decades but
they could rise even higher depending on
how long the conflict continues and
that's something that nobody can
confidently predict Nadine barber Al
Jazeera London